>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Colleen Shogan:
Good afternoon.
Welcome to the Library
of Congress.
My name is Colleen Shogan,
and I'm the deputy director
for National and International
Outreach here at the Library.
We're the division responsible
for public programming,
and the Kluge Center plays an
important role in that respect.
We'll soon hear introductions
of our esteemed panel,
but I'd like to take a
moment to briefly talk to you
about the John W.
Kluge Center directed
by Dr. John Haskell
who is on stage.
It is our scholarly center
at the Library of Congress
but has a unique mission,
namely, bringing top minds
to Capitol Hill with the
goal of informing Congress
and the larger Washington
D.C. community.
In short, the Kluge Center
aims to bridge the division
between knowledge and power.
The Kluge Center supports
visiting scholars each year,
both at the junior
and the senior levels.
We want our residential scholars
to utilize the Library's vast
collections and spend time
with our knowledgeable
experts and curators.
We also want our scholars
to share their discoveries
and insights.
The Kluge Center does that
through a variety of programming
for the general public,
for members of Congress
and for congressional staff.
In that regard, I
would be remiss
if I did not make you aware
of some terrific Kluge
programming in the near future.
Tomorrow, Dr. Bruce Jentleson,
a former Kluge Kissinger Chair,
will discuss his new
book, The Peacemakers.
That event will take
place in room 119
of the Jefferson Building
just across the street.
Additionally, there is a wide
variety of programs scheduled
for the coming weeks
ranging from Italian opera
to the Bible's role
in American history.
Please check the Kluge Center
website for more information.
Finally, we are proud to
cosponsor this event today
with the University of Denver.
I'd now like to welcome Dean
Daniel McIntosh to the stage
who will provide introductory
remarks for our panel.
>> Daniel McIntosh:
Hi, I'm Danny McIntosh.
I'm the dean of Arts,
Humanities and Social Sciences
at the University of Denver,
and it is a real pleasure
to be cohosting this
with the Kluge Center
and the Library of Congress.
The University of Denver is a
private university dedicated
to the public good.
As such a university, we
hope to engage scholars
and the community across the
nation and across the world.
We believe there should be no
barriers between scholarship
and practice, no barriers
between campus and
the community.
Therefore, we encourage and we
support our students, faculty
and staff to engage with
the wider communities
to share their scholarship
and to be in conversation
with scholars, staff people
and the community
across the country.
We want to model this
integration not only in our work
but also in our students'
experiences.
From psychology students
who prepare research reports
and plans for nonprofits
in the city of Denver
to religious study
students who work as interns
in faith-based organizations
across the country.
And from anthropology students
who work with rural Coloradans
and Japanese-Americans
interpreting the events
and the remnants of the Amache
Internment Camp, our students go
from the classroom to the field
to the lab understanding how
to integrate and tie together
scholarship and application.
One example of this
effort at the University
of Denver is the Center
on American Politics.
The Center on American
Politics is a new organization
that is interdisciplinary
that ties together scholars
from the law school, from arts,
humanities and social sciences,
political science, sociology
and international studies,
all working to understand
the very basis
of politics in America.
Politics are the way that
people's voices are heard.
It's important for us to
understand how this works.
One of the speakers today
is Professor Seth Masket,
professor in the Political
Science Department and director
of our new Center on
American Politics.
We want to be part
of the conversation.
We want to be a part of applying
our scholarship to issues
that are important to critical
issues of the time, and as such,
we are pleased to be
cosponsoring this even
with the Kluge Center and
the Library of Congress.
With that, I'd like to introduce
our moderator, John Haskell,
who's the director of
the Kluge Center here
at the Library of Congress.
Thank you.
>> John Haskell: Thank
you, Dean McIntosh.
[ Applause ]
And as Colleen pointed out a
minute ago, we're really happy
to work with the
University of Denver
because we're doing
what we both want to do,
which was to bring our
scholars, to bring scholarship
to the wider community.
And in this particular
case, we have Seth
and also two other scholars.
And I'll say a couple of
other things about Seth
that weren't mentioned.
He's already, he is the
chair in American Law
and Governance here
at the Kluge Center.
He just started in May,
and he'll be here
through the summer.
And we have other
programming in mind for him.
He is, as pointed out, the head
of the Center at the University
and is very well-regarded.
He is a classic of the kind
of scholar we try to bring
to Kluge Center because not
only is he well-respected
within the field, one of the
leaders within the field,
speaking to other academics,
he's out there on 538 and a lot
of other sites and writes
for a much larger audience.
Jennifer Victor is in
that same category.
Her PhD is from Washington
University.
She's been at George Mason
University as a professor
of American Politics
and Legislative Politics
with a specialty area
of political parties,
and we're glad to have
her for the first time
at a Kluge Center event.
Yuval Levin right here to my
right is a political scientist,
also a political philosopher
University of Chicago.
He's at the Ethics and Public
Policy Center as a fellow.
He's also the editor
of National Affairs.
He's working on a
book right now that is
on American institutions, and
he's thinking about issues
about the future
of institutions,
including the political parties.
So we're going to launch right
into questions, and I'm going
to ask Jennifer to
set the stage.
In simple terms, Jennifer,
what role do political
parties play in the US?
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor: Wow,
I didn't know I was going to be
on the hot seat first.
So, at a really basic
level, the scholarship
in political science
has thought of parties
in different concepts
over history.
The classic way that I often
describe it to students is
as a tripartite organization
that's really sort
of three separate organizations.
We think of parties in the
electorate as the partisan ship,
the party ID that voters hold.
Then we think of parties in
Congress as the organized bodies
within the legislature that
helped to pass legislation
and control agendas
and build coalitions
to achieve policy and so forth.
And the third part we think
of parties as organizations.
This is the DNC and
the RNC and all
of their component subsidiary
organizations at the national
and in the state levels.
And for a long time, scholars
have thought of this tripartite
or setup of political parties
that in some ways is quite
useful but also can be kind
of confusing because
there's a lot of crossover
and overlap interplay
between these component parts.
And a number of years
ago, sort of a new school
of thought emerged
around political parties
that conceptualized them as
more the network of actors.
Some that are policy-oriented,
some that are more
ideologically-oriented,
where the parties themselves are
made up of activists and writers
and thinkers and voters and
donors and so forth that make
up these dense coalitions
of participants.
So at the end of the day,
whichever conceptualization
we think is most useful,
given the current politics, I
think it's important to think
of parties ultimately
as organizations
that try to win elections.
A party's job is to win
seats in a legislature,
whether you're talking
about the Congress
in the state governments,
at the state level,
and the various ways
that parties do
that get kind of complicated.
One of the areas of
research that I spent a lot
of time looking at is
campaign finance and the way
that donor activity and campaign
finance activity plays into all
of those various party networks,
which I think is a big part
of the question as well.
>> John Haskell: I know
Seth and having read some
of the things you've written
that you speak similar
to what Jennifer said, parties,
a key role is screening
candidates.
And clearly, you want to
get the candidate you want
to achieve certain policy ends.
But then of course,
they've got to get elected.
Are parties today stronger
or weaker than they were
in that function say 20
years ago or 50 years ago?
>> Seth Masket: Yeah, I'm going
to do the good academic thing
and dodge the question.
It's, I don't know that
they're stronger or weaker,
but they're very different than
they were 20 or 50 years ago
in the sense that the
things a party used to do,
whether that's raise money
and spend it on advertising
or recruit candidates and train
them to run for office or,
you know, help to
organize elections,
help with voter turnout.
The formal parties don't do as
much of that as they used to.
In some ways, they're kind of
hampered from the ability to do
that due to a number of laws
that we've put in their way.
But there are other groups
that can do those things.
So for example, you know,
the democratic party works
with some democratic clubs
and some labor unions
and activists groups and
organizations like Emily's List
or the Human Rights Campaign
and other groups that do things
like train candidates
and help them get out
and organize a constituency.
And they're all more or less on
the same page with each other,
but it's very much in
the sort of network model
that Jen was talking about.
That they coordinate these
activities across dozens
of different organizations.
Now, does that mean
that they're weaker
or stronger than
they used to be?
In some ways, there
are probably some costs
to being spread apart,
spread across all these
different organizations.
They're still very polarized.
They still have a set of
beliefs they believe in.
But actually figuring
out, you know,
what's your favorite candidate
across all these different
groups can be tricky.
There's some evidence that this
fragmentation may have actually
contributed to polarization
in some ways,
because when you have money and
all these other things going
through these very
passionate activists groups,
you tend to have a
much more passionate
and ideological set
of actors involved.
Whereas, the formal
parties themselves tend
to be pretty pragmatic.
>> John Haskell: Yuval, do
you have a view on this?
I'm saving the really,
really hard question for you.
>> Yuval Levin: Oh good.
>> John Haskell:
I just want to see
if you have a view
on what Seth --
>> Yuval Levin: Well
I, well, first of all,
thank you for doing this
and for involving me in it.
I've learned an enormous amount
from Jennifer's work on Congress
over the years and from
Seth on parties is less,
but I think it's your last book,
The Inevitable Parties is really
a fantastic set of insights
on these very questions.
I think the parties are
certainly weaker than they were
if we think of them as actually
possessed of some purpose.
A party is, the goal of a
party is to allow a coalition
to cohere and to then help
that coalition win
elections and govern.
And I think that it
would be easy to show
that our coalitions have more
trouble cohering than they used
to and more trouble governing.
And I do think that
that weakening
of the parties has a lot
to do with all of that.
The fact that some of the
functions of the parties
because of campaign finance laws
and other things have been moved
to other groups means that
they're now in the hands
of groups whose function is not
to enable a coalition to cohere
and then to get elected and
to govern but rather groups
that have narrower purposes
than that and purposes
that very often are
at odds with the goal
of allowing coalition to cohere.
And I certainly think
that has a lot to do
with why we have
become more polarized.
We have this odd situation,
a number of political
scientists have pointed this
out of intense partisanship
amid weak parties.
And those things are
connected to each other.
We have turned over the
functions of parties to groups
who have much more of an
interest in polarization
and much less of an
interest in broad,
nationally electable coalitions.
And so I think the parties as
institutions are much weaker
than they used to be, and I
think we pay a price for that.
We should want them to be
stronger, though if you want
to find an unpopular cause
in American politics,
the parties are it.
>> John Haskell: So, is the
weakness of the party due
to the fact that voters, and
particularly young voters,
not really associate with
them or identify with them?
Or is that a dependent variable?
>> Yuval Levin: Well,
I think it's related.
But voters are polarized.
Voters are, even people who
call themselves independents,
as a general matter, voters now
identify themselves on the left
and right in a more coherent
way, not a less coherent way,
than you would have
found a generation ago.
And yet, the parties
are not stronger.
And I think part of that
has to do with the fact
that we have treated the parties
as institutions is part
of the problem here.
Rather than seeing them as
potentially part of the solution
to the problem of polarization.
And the parties have
just become, they've come
to have less
of an organizational
institutional existence.
They're just platforms
for individuals.
You really see that.
I mean look, half the people who
ran for president as republicans
in 2016 ran in order to
elevate their media profile.
They were just running
to get better contracts
in TV and radio.
And the party couldn't
stop that.
There was nothing they
could do about it.
In fact, I think the
person who ended up winning
and winning the presidency
probably started
out running that way.
And the party turned out to be
pretty helpless against that
because it's lost a sense of
itself as an organization,
with members, not just
the kind of open field
to populate the rest
of our democracy.
And so the loss of that
self-identity as an institution,
I think, is certainly
a sign of weakness.
>> John Haskell: Jennifer,
where are you on that question
of the overall health
of the parties?
I think Yuval made clear
his position on that.
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor:
No, I definitely agree
that parties have been
demonized in American politics.
Americans like to
point to partisanship.
And part of the reason
I think that happens is
because Americans tend
to not differentiate
partisanship from parties.
They think that's the same
word and means the same thing.
And so if republicans
and democrats
and them fighting is what's
wrong with us, that must mean
that parties is what's
wrong with us.
But in fact, these
are separate things.
Partisanship is polarized,
but parties themselves,
I'm not sure, I'm less
comfortable with describing them
as weak and more
comfortable describing them
as more highly decentralized.
I think the networks in which
they operate are much broader
and include more players
than perhaps they
did 50, 60 years ago.
But they have less central power
within each of their parties.
And I think that largely
comes from two things.
One is internal changes
within the parties themselves
about how they manage
their nomination processes
and how they funnel
their resources
and make their decisions about
who to support and so forth.
And also, laws that
govern parties.
And particularly here, laws
that govern campaign finance.
So, the main role that parties
have is to recruit candidates
and fund them and
try to win elections.
And when campaign finance
laws change in such a way
to diminish the power of
parties to do those things,
so the laws that we have on the
books now give outside groups
and any wealthy donor that wants
to use their free speech right
to go and promote a
candidate to play that role,
it weakens the power of the
party to control that process,
which is how we wound up with
the republican kerfuffle.
>> John Haskell: So there
are, you know, no --
>> Jennifer Nicoll
Victor: Technical term.
>> John Haskell:
no single component
of the political system
exists in a vacuum, of course.
So are the, is this
weakness of the parties
or the decentralization, I
guess is the word you prefer,
more symptomatic of a
larger systemic issue?
The model probably feeds
into itself, but is it,
are parties a significant
cause in it?
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor: Are
parties a cause of polarization?
>> John Haskell: Of a larger
problem in the political system.
Or are they just
symptomatic of that?
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor: So
to me, a party is an institution
that performs the very
convenient feature
of solving collective
action problems that voters
or candidates or
legislators need to solve
in order to run democracy.
So if parties didn't
exist we would create them
because we'd need
something to do that for us.
So, to me, parties
are in fact, you know,
we shouldn't be demonizing,
parties are the solution
to most of our problems.
They are mechanisms by which
we can take disparate ideas
and use them to coalesce around
something, to build on the word
that you all have used earlier.
So, where it contributes
to problems is in the idea
that we seem to think parties
are a part of the disease,
and we've weakened
the structures
on which they operate, both
internally and externally.
It's been sort of an endogenous
and exogenous force on them,
that I think contributes
in now a sort
of a self-perpetuating problem.
>> John Haskell: Where are
you on this question, Seth,
before I hit you with
another impossible question?
>> Seth Masket: I mean I tend to
agree with what Jen said here.
You know, I see parties
as essentially they do,
they're supposed to be
doing the parts of democracy
that voters themselves aren't
very good at by themselves.
They're supposed to, you know,
take really complex topics
in groups of lots of
candidates and boil them
down into fairly
simple questions
of should we do this or that.
Should we raise taxes
or lower them?
Should we make this
easier to obtain or harder?
Or this candidate
or that candidate?
And yeah, when we, you know,
when we essentially move too far
in the other direction,
it makes democracy harder.
It makes it more
confusing for people.
It makes voters want
to tune out.
>> John Haskell: So given
everything that all three
of you have said, is one party
or the other doing better?
Seth.
>> Seth Masket: I think
one party is doing worse.
So, I think, it's possible
to learn too much from 2016.
There were many ways in
which it was possibly just a
flukish year.
But the things we saw going
on in the republican
presidential nomination cycle
in 2016, I mean it was really
a pretty fascinating moment.
Generally, what happens
in presidential nominating
cycles is that, you know,
party insiders, you know,
people, activists, major donors,
people who have just been
longstanding influential
within the parties,
kind of pick a favorite.
They kind of, you know, long
before anyone starts voting
in Iowa or New Hampshire,
they kind of lean toward
one candidate or lean away
from some other group
of candidates
who they think would be bad
for the country or
bad for the party.
And the republican party just
didn't really make a choice
in 2016.
A few people came out
an endorsed Marco Rubio,
some were for Ted Cruz,
some with John Kasich,
but they were kind of split.
Most party leaders just
kind of stayed quiet.
Most members of congress
on the republican side,
governors just didn't
endorse anyone.
And that's an environment, and
when you have 17 candidates,
that's an environment in which
a very famous wealthy person can
just rise to the top in the
absence of a party signal.
And that's really what
ended up happening in 2016.
That didn't happen on
the democratic side.
The democratic party more
or less got, you know,
the candidate it wanted.
The insiders were more or less
happy with Hillary Clinton.
She had a long history
of policy stances
that were very consistent
with where the party
had been for some time.
So they basically got a
conventional candidate.
Does that mean they're
healthier?
I don't know.
Are they, they might face
the same problem in 2020
that the republicans
had in 2016.
You already have some two
dozen democrats or more
who have said they're interested
in running for office.
And you know, in the
absence of a clear kind
of preferred candidate, it
could be just as fragmented
as the republican one.
We'll be finding that out within
the next year, year and a half.
I had made a point of saying
last year and during 2016
that the presidency
is not the only thing.
That parties work with
lots of different offices.
And just because something,
there is some cracking going
on in the presidential level
doesn't mean that's going
on at the state or local level.
In fact, if you looked
at republican congressional
nominations in 2016,
they were nominating pretty
conventional candidates.
Then comes Roy Moore in Alabama.
And then there's some
evidence in this cycle
that the republican party is
nominating a lot of people just
without any history in politics.
And maybe that's good,
maybe that's bad,
but it's just there is
an unusual dynamic going
on within that party.
>> John Haskell: So Yuval,
do the republicans
have greater intentions
and ideological diversity?
I mean are they confronting
more challenges
in that realm or other realms?
>> Yuval Levin: Well, I
would say, and this relates
to the previous question
you asked too.
I do think the parties
are subject to some
of the same pressures as
everything else in our society
and that this idea
of institutions getting turned
inside out and being turned
into platforms for individuals
is actually also a way
to understand what's going
on in Congress where a lot
of members come to Congress
to get more media exposure
and don't think fundamentally
about their roles
as legislators.
It's certainly how the president
is behaving in the presidency
as a kind of performance artist.
I think you see it in the,
you see it in the professions.
It's a way to understand what's
happening in the universities.
So it shouldn't surprise us
that this is happening
to the parties.
If you had asked me
before the 2016 election,
I would have thought that the
republican party as a party was
in better shape than
the democratic party.
I think Reince Priebus
as chairman
of the RNC devoted a lot
of attention and energy
to strengthening the party as
a multistate national party.
He focused on the state parties.
He had been a state
party chairman himself.
And the work that
it had real effect.
The party as an institution
looked much stronger for it.
What he didn't do was think
at all about the party's role
in the presidential race.
I think his expectation was that
it would just happen as it had.
And when the race turned
out to be very unusual,
Reince had no plan whatsoever.
And he, as a result,
did nothing whatsoever.
The assumption was these
strange candidates would rise,
and then they'd fall.
That happened in 2012.
It happened in 2008.
You know, you'd have a period
where this populous
businessman would kind of seem
like he was leading, and
then he would disappear
and you'd have a
bunch of senators
and governors fighting it out.
And I think that the party
apparatus itself expected
that to happen until
very late in the process.
And very few, you know, there
was kind of Mike Lee screaming,
standing at the window banging
on it screaming saying
stop this.
But almost nobody else was
trying to get the party
to really act to resolve what
was basically a collective
action problem.
You know, there were too many
candidates until very late,
and I think it was
the case that any two
of them combining their efforts
might have stopped Trump even
pretty late.
And they wanted to,
and they didn't do it
because there was no way
to address the collective
action problem.
Which is exactly what
the party is for.
So, in the wake of 2016,
I think you have to say
that the republican
party looks weaker
than the democratic party.
I think it's also the case
that they now have the problem
that the democrats had
during the Obama years,
which is a president with a kind
of cultive [phonetic]
personality around him
in the party that
drives attention
and energy away from the party.
And Obama did enormous damage
to the democratic party
as an institution.
Because he himself was very
popular, and he didn't try
to use that popularity
to strengthen the party
really in any way.
So that the democrats came
out of the Obama years much
weaker as a national party.
They had much less
strength in the states.
They'd lost a lot of seats
in state legislatures
and in local races
and state races.
And a fair amount
of it had to do
with Obama drawing all the
attention and all the money.
That's exactly what is
happening now with Trump.
The party is having a lot
of trouble presenting a face
to the country, and it's
also suffering with a very,
with a very unusual generational
divide within the party.
And I think it's not
getting enough attention
but is a huge problem
for the party itself
where older republicans
love Trump.
You don't find republicans
over 60 who don't like him.
under 30 who do like him.
And the difference is very,
very intense, and it's felt
within every institution on
the right so that, you know,
that too is a kind of problem
that you would hope a
party could help deal with.
But I don't think it's in
very good shape to do it.
>> John Haskell: So Seth,
you're studying here
at the Library how the
democrats are responding
to losing the 2016 elections.
And you mentioned a minute ago
that they've got a couple
dozen people of some level
of seriousness at least.
Where are they in terms of
the mistake, if Yuval's right,
that Priebus made in not
really having a plan?
I mean, are they in a
position to have a plan,
or is the democratic
party headed to something
that might resemble
what happened
with republicans in '16?
>> Seth Masket: I mean,
part of what I've been doing
in my career in research is
just interviewing democratic
activists in various early
primary and caucus states.
And quite a few of them treated
2016 as kind of a wakeup call.
You know, they are fully
cognizant of the kind
of underinvestment
at the state level.
And, you know, they
didn't expect to lose
at the presidential level,
but then once they lost
there they looked around
and said oh my God, we've lost
all these state legislatures.
And so they're sort
of, you know,
seeing this as an important
building time for that and kind
of reinvesting a lot into
state and local candidates.
I think some of them are, you
know, feeling encouraged by some
of the special elections
that have been going
on over the last year.
And the ability of the party
to essentially pick candidates
who are appropriate for
their various districts,
conservative candidates or
at least moderate candidates
in the more conservative
districts
and pretty liberal candidates
in the more liberal districts.
But they were also, you know,
caught off guard
in so many ways.
And they're still trying to
navigate the current system.
And they definitely haven't
come up with a plan for 2020.
Most of them are not quite
thinking at that level just yet.
>> John Haskell: Jennifer,
what's your view on that?
>> Jennifer Nicoll
Victor: So, theoretically,
I think parties would
be better off
if they separated presidential
elections from state and local
and congressional elections.
Because they're two
separate processes.
And this collective action
process of coalescing
around the national candidate
during a presidential election
is a totally different type of
coordination that needs to go
on than what goes on, for
example, what we're seeing
in the midterm election
season happening right now.
And primaries where politics
really is much more local
and about congressional
districts and so for.
And we're seeing
different kinds of variation
across the primaries right now.
But I think that our
politics has become
so much more nationalized.
Our parties, I think,
are essentially severely
hampered to separate these.
I think if they could operate
as a national organization
that focuses on presidential
elections
and then local organizations
that focused on congressional
and state and local elections,
and they had the infrastructure
and the financing set up and
so forth to actually operate
that way, it would be better.
And I think it's essentially
very difficult for them to do
that now, in part, because
our politics itself is
so nationalized and partisanship
and parties are seen
as such a national thing.
And you know, we can think
about how media plays into that
and national agenda and
discussion and so forth
and just how much space there
is in any local, you know,
any local congressional
district.
The air in the room is being
sucked up by national politics.
And so it's more difficult
for the parties to play
at that diverse level.
>> John Haskell: So
are there any ways
that they can change
the way they go
about doing their business
that might address that?
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor:
I think there possibly are,
and Seth is closer to
what the parties are doing
at the more local level
and the infrastructure
of the organizations than I am.
But I have a sense that if
parties were empowering their
localities in ways that
allowed them to engage
in candidate recruitment
and candidate training
and constructing the local
issues, whatever they are,
in ways that advantaged
the partisan candidates
in local districts.
Whether that's state legislature
or congressional
districts, whatever.
That that would be
advantageous to the parties
at the national level.
But they need to have the
tools and the resources
to be able to localize.
And the parties have
to be willing
to have a local candidate
that flies off the rails
and maybe doesn't follow
the national agenda
on a particular issue.
But in general, politics is
not about issues these days.
The partisanship and the
parties and the camps
in which we see ourselves
as partisans is really driving
people's taste for politics.
So it, to me, that
should empower parties
to like let the issues go.
The issues don't matter.
It almost doesn't matter what
issues the local candidates are
going to talk about because
the partisanship is going
to rule the day anyway.
>> John Haskell: Do you all
have a view on, when you read
about what's going on
within the democratic party
and the primaries, Seth
made an observation
about the republicans this year.
You know, we're going
back to Roy Moore.
And it's sort of the Sanders
and other progressive
organizations doing battle,
you know, with democrats
who want to see candidates
who might be slightly
more moderate.
Where is the democratic
party on this?
Are they headed for
some sort of crackup?
Or is this just really
just about style?
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor:
We need another cycle.
We don't know yet.
>> John Haskell: Don't know yet.
Time to make a prediction.
>> Yuval Levin: Well look,
I think they are going
through a fight between
their activists
and their elected officials,
especially in Washington
that is interesting to watch.
Democrats in Washington
I think have a sense
that they should not go too far
and that they cannot make Trump
the focus of everything they do.
But the activists' energy
wants to do just that.
And that's a problem
that's very similar
to the one republicans
faced in dealing
with Barack Obama
during the last
presidential administration.
I think the democrats have
the added pressure here.
If they win the House,
they're going to need
to impeach the president.
It'll be very hard for them
to avoid at least starting
that process because that's
where their activists are.
And I would say the leaders
of the democratic party
in Washington do
not want to do that,
because they don't
think it would be good
for the party going forward.
But good luck to them
trying to stop it.
I think they will be under
immense pressure to do it.
So it's not a crackup
in the sense
that the party falls apart,
but I think that it's intense
pressure that is the kind
of thing that a party might
exist to help address.
And so it'll be a test.
>> John Haskell: So Jennifer,
you brought up campaign finance,
you know what do we need
to look at and think
about if there were going
to be reforms in that area
or either changes in
the ways the parties go
about their business?
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor:
Yeah, so it's a sticky issue.
It's very complicated.
But the, so the Supreme Court,
so we changed the campaign
finance law in 2002
under what was known as
the McCain Feingold Bill.
And then it got updated
again in 2010
with the Supreme Court decision
and some following
FEC decisions known
as Citizens United
and then Speech Now.
And the result of those reforms
over that period are a
great decentralization
of our campaign finance
system where the parties used
to have quite a bit of
power in controlling things,
and there was this soft money.
Everybody was worried about the
soft money through all the 70s,
80s and 90s, and this was the
big thing that John McCain
and his various political
partners were all worried about.
The parties were being used
as a basically a money
laundering machine
that were allowing donors to
funnel as much unlimited money
as they want to candidates.
But it turns out in retrospect,
that money laundering was
somewhat healthy for the system
because it was giving
the parties control
over where the money went.
So what we have now is the soft
money in that sense is gone.
The parties aren't doing
that funneling anymore
because of the ways
the laws have changed.
But that money is
still out there,
and it's just happening
on its own.
So whatever wealthy donors
or organizations or activists
or whoever want to get involved,
they're out there
picking their candidates
or picking their horse in
local races or national races
and just going after them.
Now to stay within the
confines of the law,
they technically are not allowed
to coordinate with the parties.
Otherwise, then it's seen
as a campaign donation,
and it's limited by law.
So they're in this
atmosphere where they can raise
as much money as they
want in this unlimited way
without the party
filter that tends
to kind of moderate things.
So, it would be helpful, I
think, to change the laws
in a way that strengthens
parties,
that gave parties more control
over where the money came
from and where it went.
It's not clear to me what the
viable, either legislative
or judicial path to make
that happen is at this point.
>> John Haskell: Yeah.
What do you think, Seth?
>> Seth Masket: Just on the --
>> John Haskell:
Yeah, the question --
>> Seth Masket: Fixing
the party kind of thing?
>> John Haskell: Yeah,
fixing the parties broadly
but on the campaign
finance side.
You know, because, you know,
Jennifer refers back in the 90s,
you know, Clinton allegedly
rented out the Lincoln bedroom.
So that made it look bad even
if it was good for the party,
right, to do that kind of thing.
And then yeah, you
know, he found,
I guess his people found the
big loophole at that time.
Is there something that
we don't know about now?
Well, of course, if we
don't know about it,
we can't talk about it, right.
But you know, we have to think
a little bit outside the box.
There's going to be reform,
you know, things that worked
in the past probably
aren't going to work now
for all kinds of reasons.
You know, where are you on that?
>> Seth Masket: Yeah, I mean,
the problem, this is the basis
of my last book, you know,
every time we reform them,
there's all these
unanticipated consequences
that we don't always
think about.
And, you know, when
you attempt to sort
of wall off a certain
type of spending,
the money is going
to get there somehow.
If someone wants to so spend on
a race, someone wants to donate
to a candidate, somehow,
that money is going
to get into the system.
It's just a matter of, you know,
every time we cut off a
certain barrier for it,
we make that money
less traceable.
And we make the system of
just tracking who donated
to whom a lot harder to follow.
Which is generally
undesirable things.
Yeah, I would love to see,
you know, similar with Jen,
I would love to see more
of, more funding going
through the formal party system.
I would love to see the parties
themselves have more power
to allocate that money rather
than sending it across,
you know, 100 different groups.
You know, more generally,
just kind of outside
of the campaign finance
system, and this is, I know,
an uphill battle,
but I would love
to see the parties
being less democratic.
That is --
>> John Haskell: Small D.
>> Seth Masket: Yeah,
yeah, small D democratic.
That is, you know, more
elite-driven, less, you know,
less subject to what individual
members within the party want.
The Democratic National
Committee right now,
this summer, is probably,
they're working
on some sort of reforms.
They're probably
they're going to get rid
of their superdelegate
system, or they're going
to substantially sort of
disempower the superdelegates.
The superdelegates
are, of course,
the people within the party.
They're DNC members.
They're elected officials
who have a vote
at the nominating convention,
regardless of what
primary voters want.
And just as some of the
reforms coming out of 2016,
they're going to substantially
disempower those people
most likely.
And which is in some ways
remarkable given what they saw
going on in the republican
side in 2016
where in many ways it leads
to not have enough control
over what was going on.
They're moving in
that same direction
that the republicans moved.
Now, I haven't been
hugely impressed
with the power superdelegates
have
or the power they're willing
to exercise to push back
against their own party voters.
But if anything, the parties
seem to be moving in more
of a small D democratic
direction.
Which I think in some ways
carries a lot of danger.
>> John Haskell: And I
know, Yuval, a lot of,
when you read a lot
about a republican
or conservative intellectual
said well let's have the
republican party, let's define
it the way we want to define it,
free trade, low taxes, etcetera,
cutting back on entitlements,
and Trump doesn't fit that.
You know, there's a lot of talk
in conservative intellectual
circles.
And so let's be clear
what our party is about
and that there are
short-term consequences.
But nobody really had the
power to do that, right.
I mean, is that effort
still going on?
Is there any prospect of
success for that kind of effort?
>> Yuval Levin: Well, I
think that it's not been much
of an actual concrete effort.
I do agree that there are ways
to re-empower the parties some
in our system relative to
the other forces at work.
And I think that allowing the
parties to raise much more money
but in a more transparent
way, we sort of have
to ask ourselves, what is
the least illegitimate place
for all that money to go?
And I think the parties are
the answer to that question.
So that, because their goal
is to create broad coalitions.
And that's what we have to
want our politics to involve.
And so I think we ought to allow
the parties to be the place
where a lot of money goes
provided that it is transparent.
And it also seems to me that the
party is gaining some control
over their own processes
are a way to address some
of these problems, as Seth
suggests, that the parties have
to realize that they are owners
of very, very powerful brands.
They have a banner.
And whoever gets that banner in
a presidential election is going
to get at least 45% of
the vote in that election.
Literally whoever they are.
I mean, if we have learned
anything, it is that.
And so they have got to realize
that that is an immense
responsibility.
And to take very seriously the
responsibility they have to own
that banner that comes
with 45% of the vote
in a presidential election.
You know, that person
is basically going
to have pretty much an even
shot of becoming president.
So they need to think about how
they choose who that person is,
because they have an
obligation to the country.
And at this point,
they just fall
down on the job in doing that.
They allow it to
happen of its own.
I think republicans
have a tendency
to following the
democrats in setting rules.
They're kind of lackadaisical
in setting rules
for nominating processes.
The rules of the presidential
nominating process now were
adopted after the democrats
after I think a pretty
thoughtful process in the 1970s
where they really fought
out their differences.
And the process that
emerged from that is suited
to the dynamics
of the democratic
coalition at the time.
And then the republican party
just adopted it wholesale
without really thinking
about how it related
to its own coalition.
Something like that
is happening again.
I think the democrats
are talking about how
to change the process.
I don't know if they'll
be able to do it,
but they're at least
thinking about it.
There's really nothing
at all like that going
on that I can see on
the republican side.
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor:
I just wanted to add
that thinking about, I
think it's worthwhile
to take a slightly longer view
in thinking about how we got
to this point where our parties
are relatively decentralized.
Because I think there's
a tradeoff, right.
So, if you go back to the
early part of the 19th
or 20th century, what you had
were really centralized parties.
You, in fact, had party bosses
in the proverbial
smoke-filled room.
And these, you know,
a couple of people
who basically made all the
choices about who were going
to be the candidates and
where the money was going
to go and so forth.
And that system was
incredibly correct.
And it was easily captured,
and it was very un-small
D democratic.
And so the push in the 100
years since then, I think,
has been towards more
democratization of the parties
to give the voters
greater influence in all
of those things, the candidate
selection and recruitment
and everything that parties do.
And what we're seeing
now is we're
at the other end
of that spectrum.
And what we're seeing is,
there's huge costs
to this end as well.
And so there's essentially
a tradeoff, I think,
between centralized parties
and decentralized parties
where at one end you
get left polarization
and really effective clean
results but with corruption.
And at the other end, you get
dysfunction and disorganization.
But we don't have that kind
of corruption that we used
to be worried about
like, I mean,
yeah you get a Jack
Abramoff story or something
like that every once in a while,
but those are really
pretty rare these days.
Like we've really
gotten rid of that type
of corruption in our politics.
And the price that we're paying
for it is this dysfunction,
this terrible polarization.
>> John Haskell: We focus
on the glass half-full --
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor: So I
feel like there's an equilibrium
to be had in the middle, but the
parties, it's not clear to me
at all the parties as an
organizations, if I could speak
of them as having
a central brain,
are aware of the necessity
of finding that equilibrium.
>> John Haskell: Before
we get to some questions
from the audience, I wanted to,
you know, play off on one thing
that Yuval said, and I think
he's right, that each party kind
of starts with 45% in a
presidential election.
Sometimes they don't
get much more than that.
But and so, democratic
banner, republican banner,
Seth what's the chances
there could be a different
banner sometime?
What would that look like?
>> Seth Masket: Not large.
Well, I mean, I mean --
>> John Haskell: I mean
France suddenly, you know,
overnight suddenly they have
a guy getting all the votes
and getting all the
legislative seats.
Different system.
And now Italy is
doing the same thing.
I mean sometimes, you know,
sometimes what happens
in Europe affects us here.
It doesn't always go
the other direction,
even if we'd like to think that.
And so there's something
out there that's a
dissatisfaction obviously
that I don't know whether
it's reached that level
or whether our system is more,
you know, ossified or something.
>> Seth Masket: You know, I
mean, this is one of those areas
where I think we
probably focus too much
on the presidential level
where the two party outcomes
just are very resilient.
I mean you could possibly see
a scenario where, you know,
Trump suddenly becomes
very unpopular.
There's a recession or
something like that.
If republicans want to
run someone else in 2020,
and he splits off and
forms his own party.
I mean you could sort of
see something like that
but probably not
lasting in the long run.
There was a fascinating
sort of counterexample
to this in Colorado in 2010.
There was a gubernatorial
election.
That's where the democrats
first elected John Hickenlooper.
The republicans threw
a bizarre series of,
it was a big tea party rally,
and it was a scandal for sort
of the favorite candidate.
And this little-known tea party
activist named Dan Mayes ended
up getting the republican
nomination
through the primary there.
And the republican
party didn't like him.
Like all the republican
leaders said this guy is
totally irresponsible.
He was going all over the place
with these very paranoid
theories
about how the UN
was going to take
over through a bike sharing
program and that sort of thing.
He was quite sincere.
So a lot of state republican
leaders backed Tom Tancredo
as a third-party candidate
to run for governor.
Knowing it was probably
going to split the vote
but basically saying we
don't want to win with this.
We don't, we think this is
actually bad for the party
in the long run if we all
rallied behind our nominee.
And it did split
the republican vote,
and Hickenlooper won
in a pretty easy run.
But that sort of thing happens
a little more at the state
and local level than
you definitely see
at the presidential level.
But again, the two-party
system is so deeply engrained
and so favored by the
systems we have here.
If we did have a third party,
it would likely become the
second party very quickly
if the other party
just disappeared.
>> John Haskell: Any
thoughts on that Yuval?
>> Yuval Levin: Well, I agree.
I think we've seen
that a little bit.
The durability of
a two-party system,
even when the federalists or the
Whigs went away pretty quickly
or back to a two-party system,
the 1912 presidential race
where the republicans
were really split,
and there were really
two republican candidates
and three presidential
candidates.
That seemed like the end
of the republican party.
And one cycle later, the party
was back basically to itself.
And so, you know, a part of it
is structural in the first past
to post election system
and the rest of it.
I think our system
really is just geared
to a two-party system.
That doesn't mean it
could never change,
but I think the parties
have survived times
that have been more
dramatically problematic
than what they're
going through now.
It could get crazier.
It could get worse.
But I don't see it
at this point.
>> John Haskell: Thank
you all for your insights.
We'll move to some questions.
Let's bring it up to the
gentleman in the front.
Wait, we've got a
microphone for you here.
>> How does like polarization
in the general population
play a part in this?
Like, I've noticed, at
least in my lifetime,
it's really increased
how people are very,
either extremely democratic
or extremely republican.
I mean it happens in my
school, and it happens
in people older than me.
>> Yuval Levin: You know,
one of the striking things
about polarization is the most
aggressively partisan people
hate their parties
on both sides.
And so there is a way in which
strengthening polarization
actually undermines the strength
of the parties as institutions,
as organizations, and
empowers these smaller groups
that represent kind of
subcultures within the party.
And so I think it's
not a coincidence
that we've seen increasing
polarization at the same time
as weakening institutional
parties.
Part of what the parties do is
broaden their own coalitions
and allow a republican who's
running in Massachusetts
to be a little less
conservative than a republican
who is running in Texas.
And that becomes more difficult
to do as polarization grows
and the parties weaken
at the same time.
>> John Haskell: Who else
had something over here?
Greg, that guy in the middle.
>> Hi. Thank you all for coming
out to the Library
of Congress today.
I just had a question
regarding the future of parties
in regards to voter systems.
And I'm based in New England
recently, and there's been a lot
of talk about Maine and perhaps
Vermont adopting the instant
runoff choice system of voting.
Which would most likely
theoretically collapse the idea
of big time coalitions,
but at the same time,
give people more fluidity
when it comes to elections.
If something like this was
implemented or advocated
for at the national level,
could you see it succeeding?
And if so, what do you
think the outcome would be?
>> John Haskell: Seth
might should speak to that.
>> Seth Masket: Oh man.
>> John Haskell:
Sorry about that.
That's a great question.
>> Seth Masket: I think
it's actually trying
to implement something
like instant runoff voting
at the national level.
There's a lot of
questions in there.
Are we talking about
making that part
of the electoral college
calculation within every state?
Are we talking about an
actual national popular vote?
There's a lot of
changes that would have
to occur to get to that point.
It's potentially an
interesting case though.
And it's possible to
see if you had some sort
of like a national
primary system
with instant runoff voting.
You might have had, you know,
the republicans might have come
up with something very different
than Donald Trump
last time around.
If you have, if there's no
one who everyone, you know,
seems to like for their
first-round choice,
but everyone is sort of
okay with John Kasich
or something like that.
You could end up with that
sort of a consensus nominee.
There was, I mean
even going back to,
there was some great quote
from when Lincoln was running
in 1860, that his whole
strategy, I think,
it was actually a quote from
him saying my whole strategy is
to be everyone's second
favorite candidate.
You know, just so, so all of the
sort of most passionate people
on every side of the party just
kind of cancel each other out.
They all say yeah, but
I'd be okay with him.
And that's kind of
how you get in.
And I think something
like instant runoff voting
actually helps that occur.
>> John Haskell: We've
got somebody over here.
Right there, Mike.
>> Hi, thanks for coming out.
So my question is
a bit reflective.
When I was younger, I am older,
a lot older than what I look.
So when I was younger, I did
ten years in the Marine Corps,
so I always had this mindset
that you can pull yourself
up by your bootstraps.
Now that I'm 40 plus
and have two kids,
one 17 and 15, I've
been a teacher.
And I've seen that that is not
the case for African-Americans.
So as I taught fourth grade,
teaching them the 13th,
14th and 15th Amendments, and
especially that 14th Amendment
about equality for
African-Americans.
And we were discussing the
Brown versus Board of Education.
And I've lived in
many states before,
but then I started
reading and learning
about how Virginia was able
to circumvent that Brown
versus Board of Education
and how
that still plays a part
today in our education system
and how negatively it
impacts African-Americans.
And I was talking to my husband
yesterday, and I was like,
where could an African-American
mom, our family go
to an African-American
community that is thriving?
That you have doctors, lawyers,
hospitals that look like you,
there's very few
places that you can go.
And I asked him that question
because I spent a year
as a teacher in a
very wealthy community
where teachers did
not want to work
with me simply because
of my color.
That never happened to
me in the Marine Corps.
And I can say well, thank God
for all the African-Americans
that came before me.
But why would I want to put
my kids through that ordeal?
Why would they have to
endure that simply because,
and then I don't, republican or
democratic, there's not enough
of African-Americans
to make it a valid,
that we have a valid say.
So regardless of
what party is voting,
when do we get past the
nationalism of isms?
When do we get past
that and look
at people for their humanity.
Because we're spending
so much money making sure
that other countries do it
right, but we don't do it right.
And I can't send my kids, my
daughter graduates next year.
I don't feel comfortable sending
her into a work environment
that she has to endure
what I endured
and am still enduring simply
because we raise communities
to believe that we're one better
than the other because of isms.
How do we address that?
>> John Haskell: So I think one
of the ways we could maybe talk
about that is to talk about
how is it that minorities,
whether ethnic or racial
or other, you know,
sexual orientation,
other minorities,
how do they get influenced
within the party system?
You know, what's a good
way to think about that?
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor: So
to me, part of what's going
on in polarization in
American politics right now,
and you're speaking primarily
about the African-American
community, which is largely
for the last 50 years or so
been kind of solidly married
to the Democratic party.
For, largely, I was going
to say for better or worse,
but really it's for worse that
throughout American history,
one party or the other has
essentially always kind of been,
I don't want to put this
impolitely, but sort of married
to the racist devil, right.
So for lots of the 19th century
and into the 20th century,
it was the democratic party.
They were the party of slavery.
They were the party that
controlled the South and fought
to maintain slavery and
then ultimately lost.
But then found various
institutions to kind
of keep that culture going.
Until you get to the middle
part of the 20th century,
and the democratic party
reforms on that issue.
And you get actors like John
F. Kennedy and LBJ and others
who pick up the mantle
of civil rights.
The African-American has sort
of opportunistically
bringing this new portion
of the electorate
into the party.
They did that quite well.
The republican party
responds and pivots
by following what Nixon
called the southern strategy.
And that sets off the
democratic and American
and republican parties on their,
what is now their current path
in which the democratic party
much more strongly holds the
mantle of civil rights.
And the republican party is
often the counter to that.
And so part of what I think
perpetuates this and prevents us
from getting beyond
it in some of the ways
that you're expressing
is that as a country,
we've never really
reconciled how
to get beyond our
legacy of slavery.
We've never done a very
good job as a country
of showing complicity there and
showing some sense of contrition
for the role that we played
in perpetuating that economy
for hundreds of years.
And it's now completely baked
into our political parties
in ways that is divisive
rather than in ways
that promote some
kind of healing.
And lots of institutions
perpetuate this.
I'm not just talking about
structural racism, but I mean,
federalism itself, the
fact that we have states
and United States Senate, like
all of these institutions were
in some ways created
to perpetuate slavery.
And our inability to
overcome that issue
and to really fully
reconcile with it as a country
and as a people I think
has it much more baked
into our politics in ways
that are really difficult
to reconcile at this point
until we get political actors
who decide they want
to try to address that.
So I often think about in the
post-Nazi period in Germany,
you can't go into a town village
or hamlet in all of Germany
without finding some memorial
somewhere to the Holocaust.
It's a part of the
national identity.
national culture
to show some national contrition
for their participation
in that genocide.
And the Americans never
done that with slavery.
And I think that affects the
way our partisan politics deals
with that issue even today.
>> John Haskell: So we have time
for one or two more questions.
We'll take these two here.
David and then the
woman in front.
>> Hi, I have a question
about party coalitions
and evolving party coalitions.
So, as all of you know, there's
an education realignment that's
occurred where the democrats
now have something close
to a 25-percentage point
advantage among whites
with college degrees.
That wasn't true
even 15 years ago.
They have a 35-percentagge
point advantage with whites
with advanced degrees.
And I wonder how long
a party coalition
on both sides can continue
in terms of the policies
that they advocate not
match its constituency.
Because at the same time while
we have this difference in terms
of education, we also
see a closer correlation
between education and income
than we did even
a generation ago.
And so, at some point, you would
expect actually the democrats
to flip and start advocating for
lower taxes and less regulation.
It's not happening right now,
but I wonder if you guys want
to speculate about what
will happen in a generation.
>> John Haskell: Tough question.
Either of you guys
want to say something.
>> Yuval Levin: Sure,
I won't speak
to about what'll
happen in a generation.
Having gone through
2016, I don't even speak
about what will happen
next Wednesday.
But I do think that we shouldn't
overestimate the degree
to which economic
interests drives voter's
self-understanding about
political interest.
One of the things we've been
learning in this century
about our politics is
that people who care
about what we think
of as kind of cultural
and identity issues
much more than they care
about economic issues.
And in some ways both
of the parties now are
advocating things that are
against the economic interests
of their core constituents.
And you know, republicans
are the party of the elderly
that wants to change
social security,
or they used to want to.
They're the party of the
working class that wants
to lower their boss' taxes.
If you think about economics
that way, I mean politics
that way as an extension
of economics,
it just doesn't make sense.
But the part coalition makes
more sense if you think
about what it is that people
in this economic
brackets value most
and what they care about,
what they believe in.
I think in that way, the
coalitions make some more sense.
And so it may be that what
you're really seeing is
that higher income people
in America have certain
cultural attitudes and views
that incline them more
toward the leftwing party
and our politics, and
the working-class people
in America tend to have more
conservative views on the issues
that they care about most.
So, you know, it used to be said
that conservatives care more
about the culture and liberals
care most about the economy.
But the right keeps
winning on the economy,
and the left keeps
winning on the culture.
So we're kind of
permanently frustrated.
I think we're actually
at a point now
where both coalitions
seem to care most
about cultural issues
one way or another.
>> John Haskell:
Okay, last question.
We have one of our friends
form the University of Denver.
>> Thank you.
More women than ever are
running for office this year,
and I wanted to know, what do
we think the increased number
of women eventually
holding office,
if that will change anything
within the political
party system.
>> John Haskell:
That's a great question.
I think both Jennifer
and Seth speak to that
in whichever order you'd like.
>> Jennifer Nicoll Victor:
So the literature suggests
that once women win office,
they tend to legislate
much the same way men do.
That being said, so on one hand
you might not think actually
politics would be very much
different in terms of policy.
On the other hand, there's
a good amount of literature
that suggests that women tend
to sort of behave differently
in office as leaders,
as managers,
as running either their personal
offices or their committees
or whatever position
it is that they have.
And I'm thinking of
members of Congress.
And so it could be that
there are more subtle forms
of negotiation or
management or politicking
that changes operations at a
level that's more difficult
for scholars like us to observe.
Except perhaps in the long run.
So I guess I'm of
mixed mind about this.
On the one hand, I think
creating a Congress
that looks more like
America is a good thing.
We know that there are huge
advantages to having some level
of descriptive representation.
Whether that's race
or gender or whatever.
On the other hand, we also know
that once a minority group,
whether you're talking about
race or women or whatever,
come into office, and they
reach a certain level,
they tend to sort of wind up
acting just like the people
who were there before.
So, there are dividends to
be paid on the front side.
I think for recruiting of more
diverse crop of candidates
to run for office, and it might
be that there will be dividends
to pay in politicking
and management
of politics in the long run.
How exactly we observe that
in policy is a little bit more
abstract, I think.
>> Seth Masket: Hey Julie.
So, check me if I'm wrong here,
but I think women tend to be,
within both parties, women tend
to be more liberal than men.
You know, both within
their republican
and within the democratic
parties.
And so, you know,
that, you know,
as their numbers increase
among elected officials,
that tends to suggest
it will somewhat change.
It could end up making the
republican party more moderate.
democratic party more liberal.
And interestingly, it's not
just on thing, it's not even
on things like reproductive
rights,
where actually women's views
and men's views are very
similar it turns out.
But on just sort of
general economic issues,
on general social
welfare issues.
That could have the effect
of moving the system
somewhat to the left.
Now, it depends where these
women are getting electing.
My understanding is most of
them are running as democrats.
Most of the women
who are running
for Congress right now
are running as democrats.
So that'll probably
have a greater effect
on the democratic party than
on the republican right now.
But yeah, we could
see a different effect
across both parties.
>> John Haskell: Well thank
you all three for your insights
on the future of
political parties.
And thank you for attending.
We have a reception here, and --
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.